of people in therein. That the
individual should begin with to
they should initiate their
entrance into the Masjid by
praying to Raqah. After this,
the person may approach whoever
they are going to sit with and
initiate that encounter with a
Salem by saying
Masjid. Masjid.
Masjid.
[Silence]
this salah is referred to often
times by the scholars of
Islamic jurors. These two are
referred to as the salutation
prayer of the Masjid. What is
meant by the salutation prayer
of the Masjid. What's meant by
this is that when an individual
enters the Masjid that they do
not treat the Masjid as they do
any other building or any other
home. The Masjid is special. It
is sacred and it has a right.
It holds a right over. It's
attendee and so, what's in
what's meant here is that when
a person enters the Masjid,
they are to pray and start
there and begin their time in
the Masjid with prayer, with
salah. If there is a salah
going on or if they have a
prayer to make, that is fine.
It doesn't have to be too
right? So, for instance, let's
say a person comes to the
Masjid and have to make for
instance. The and they want to
make as well to masjid. Masjid.
They can just make two raka for
for because what's intended
here is that a person initiate
and begin his time in the
Masjid with salah. For this
reason, the companions of all
the when they would to the
masjid and is going on, They
would join the immediately And
they would pray the with the
prophet and that's it. They
wouldn't stand up after that
prayer and make two raka. If it
was necessary, those two raka
were intended essentially, then
yes, according to the patterns
and the principles of they
would stand up after salah and
make two raka for the masjid
but this is not something that
they would do. Because they
understood that the two for
salutation of the masjid.
What's intended is not
necessarily two raka. What's
intended is that a person begin
his time in the Masjid.
Initiate himself into the
Masjid. With Salah. With salah.
So if a person enters the
Masjid and there's no salah
going on. And they don't have
any salah to make. And they
just want to in the Masjid and
sit or spend time in the
Masjid. then in this case, the
person would make two raka and
their intention for these two
raka is salutation of the
Masjid. Masjid, right?
Otherwise, any salah will do as
long as a person begins his
time in the Masjid with salah.
This is what is intended.
[Silence]
So, that's the first
responsibility. The first thing
we do when we enter the Masjid,
we enter with our right foot
and we say, bismillah,
the next thing, the next
responsibility, Is that the
person prays in Masjid that
they pray at least. We say at
least two raka. as salutation
to the masjid. He says, and
then the person says to whoever
they approach in the Masjid.
It's not to be understood from
this. That if a person walks
into the masjid and there's
somebody standing right at the
door that they don't say salaam
alaikum. That's not what's
intended. Because what's meant
here is that you enter the
masjid from a distance. The the
door is far from where people
are sitting. So, you enter the
door, you enter the masjid.
Before you approach whoever
you're going to spend your time
within the Masjid, you pray to
Masjid. You pray to Raka and
then you come and approach them
and say assalamu alaikum. It
doesn't mean that you ignore
anyone on your way. If you
enter the masjids, the people
standing on the stairs, people
in the office, people in. When
you walk by them, you salaam
alaikum because we learned
before that the person who
passes those who are standing
says a salaam to them, right?
Person who is younger says
salaam to the one who is older.
We mentioned all of those. Last
week. Yakulu, Ibnal Kaim then
says, with regards to the way
that the prophet would convey a
salam is that if he would enter
his home at night, At night,
meaning people are usually
sleeping, right? He would say a
Salem in a low voice.
A voice soft enough that if
someone were sleeping, their
sleep would not be disturbed.
Yet, if someone were awake,
they would hear him. So, you
walk into your house and you
know, someone's sleeping on the
couch. You would say, assalamu
alaikum and a voice low enough
that it wouldn't disturb them
if they were sleeping but if
they were awake, they could
hear you and respond to a this
is how the prophet would convey
a salaam to someone who is
sleeping. He mentions a
narration collected by that a
salaam should proceed Kalem. As
Salam saying assalamu alaikum.
Should proceed come before
speaking. So, when you want to
speak to someone, you want to
initiate conversation with
someone who is Muslim, you
begin with. Assalamu alaikum.
and Imam Ahmed collected in his
on the authority of that the
prophet said the salutation of
a salaam should proceed any
question, you know, when you go
to someone's house or you go
into the Masjid or especially
the prophet he would be in the
masjid. People would come
looking for him. They have
questions to ask him. They have
issues they need to address. he
would say should be your
question, your inquiry,
whatever it is, the favor
you're asking, it should be
preceded by by Assalam. You
begin with a Salam and then you
ask for whatever it is that
you've come for. and he then
said, and so whoever begins
does not begin with or begins
with their question or what
they're seeking before Assalam
then do not answer his request.
Allah